some Garden crops belong in containers
and space is money when you're trying to
grow high value foods for your nutrition
and your budget containers can solve a
lot of problems for us like reducing
pests and weeds to name a couple when we
have more control in the garden we're
less stressed in the garden I'm a solo
Gardener downsizing my 28 raised bed
garden in just a few weeks and I'll show
you the top three crops I've been
growing in containers in my large garden
and the three I can't wait to get into
containers I'll also show you which
containers I've found to help these
plants Thrive and
[Music]
how before we dive way in here are nine
ways containers can help you grow what
you want to grow in your garden first
they allow you to grow food in small
spaces and make the best of larger
spaces you can easily move them to
optimize the sunlight exposure protect
plants from harsh weather or rearrange
your garden layout as needed since you
can move your containers indoors or to
sheltered areas to protect plants from
frost this actually allows you to more
effortlessly extend your growing season
growing plants in containers can help
reduce the risk of soil born diseases
and pests you have more control over the
soil which can minimize these issues you
can choose the perfect soil mix for each
type of plant ensuring they get the
right nutrients and conditions for
optimal growth for example blueberries
they just require more acidic soil than
many other Garden crops you can easily
Implement efficient watering systems
like drip irrigation to minimize water
usage and add soil amendments to help
conserve water growing in containers
usually results in fewer weeds saving
you a lot of time and a lot of effort
maintaining your garden and they can be
set at a height that reduces the need
for bending and kneeling making
gardening a lot easier on our bodies
finally I think containers are perfect
for trying out new crops and gardening
techniques without a significant
investment of time or space I've found
over the years that getting out and
experimenting in the garden allows you
to learn so much valuable information to
increase productivity and value now
let's talk about these six amazing
Garden crops and then at the end of the
video I'm going to show you which
containers keep plant roots super
healthy most herbs are extremely
adaptable easy to grow and require
little attention making them perfect for
containers even though I've been growing
in a large garden space I've always
grown my herbs in containers to keep the
garden beds free for other things
especially herbs like mint that spread
are perfect for containers because
they're prevented from being invasive
this way perennial herbs like chives are
also perfect because they need to be
divided every year or two to stay
productive and then it's easy to do in
containers herbs are plants I'm
constantly harvesting from too so I like
the option of moving them where they're
easy for me to access quickly instead of
having to walk all the way out to the
Garden I can move them closer to my back
door even since I've been growing in a
garden with 28 raised beds I faced the
challenge of crop rotation tomatoes are
a good example because they're so
disease prone and I usually grow a lot
of them because I like to make salsa and
sauce so sometimes it's challenging to
not plant tomatoes or other plants of
the same family in the same spot during
consecutive growing Seasons planting at
least some of them in containers really
help solve this problem because they
give you more flexibility spacewise here
I have a monino tomato plant and a
container this is an indeterminate
variety which takes some pruning and
staking to keep it under control in a
container and then this right here is a
midnight roma tomato plant which is
semi- determinant most semi determinate
tomato plants are actually just
indeterminate plants with a bushier
growth habit like determinate
determinate plants are more Compact and
can be easier to grow in containers than
indeterminate although both are going to
be fine in containers indeterminant are
just a little more high maintenance to
keep them supported I would still
recommend staking and caging either
variety and if you do have a tomato
plant that becomes diseased it's easier
to quarantine it from your other plants
when it's in a container it's also
easier to replace the soil and get rid
of soil born diseases and pests that
overwinter in the soil growing peppers
in containers has allowed me to
experiment with different varieties over
the years I've had my main varieties
that I grow for preserving in raised
beds where I usually grow 12 plants in
each 4x8 which are jalapeno Lively
Italian orange sweet bell and pimento so
having containers on hand allows extra
space to experiment with other varieties
I found that some varieties are more
compact than others like these mini
bells that I have right here so you can
grow pepper and containers even if you
have a small garden space and doing this
also can help free up space in a larger
Garden to allow you to grow other things
these are the three crops I've regularly
grown in containers and next are the
three I can't wait to get into
containers when I'm growing in my
downsize Garden potatoes take up a lot
of space in the garden and a large
amount of them can be grown in
containers which frees up space for
growing things like squash I'm planning
on planting some next spring in my 10
gallon grow bags you can fit around
three potato plants in a 10 gallon
container and I've grown things in 25
gallon ones before and they get
extremely heavy the thing I'm most
excited about is just dumping the
potatoes out to harvest as opposed to
digging them up out of my raised beds
which is a lot more work potatoes don't
like compacted soil and you have a lot
more control over your soil in smaller
containers making this a lot easier to
accomplish for a good potato Harvest I
can't wait to plant my potatoes in
containers for the first time next
spring which is going to be April where
I live I've had a lot of garden space
taken up by June bearing strawberries
over the past 10 years plus I rotate my
beds and plant fresh Runners every year
to make sure we have those big June
bearing Harvest every year I made a
video about this if you'd like to see
how to propagate June bearing strawberri
so you never have to buy the plants
again if you don't want to so I've been
thinking about how I'm going to continue
my strawberry growing in a much
downsized Garden space since we eat lots
of strawberries and growing our own
saves so much money I'd love to try a
vertical planter and I might try an
everbearing variety since they produce
fewer runners I've seen several
gardening friends have success with
growing lots of strawberries in vertical
growing towers and I think I'm going to
give it a shot next spring and last but
probably not least I can't wait to plant
as much of my lettuce as possible in
containers to free up space for things
like corn which by the way you can also
grow in containers depending on how much
of it you want to grow I like to plant
cutand come again lettuce that you plant
densely and harvest mostly as baby
greens and then the plants grow back to
give you a few harvests before it
becomes tough and bitter This lends
itself well to containers because you
can tuck a lot of cutand come again
lettuce into each one since it's densely
planted succession planting also works
well in containers where you sew seeds
every couple of weeks so you have a
continuous supply of fresh lettuce you
can easily just rotate your containers
as you succession plant lettuce is a
cool season crop so you can conveniently
move your containers out of hot sun to
extend time before the plants Bolt from
heat stress I've been experimenting a
lot with grow bags for the past five
years or so and they're my container of
choice here's what I've learned plants
don't become root Bound in grow bags
because the grow bags are porous when
the roots reach the edges they reach the
air and stop growing in that direction
and they're air pruned there's also just
enough air circulation through the walls
of the grow bags that the root system
thrives when Roots reach the edges of
plastic containers they keep growing
until they're all constrained and
Tangled and the plants become root bound
grow bags are kind of like little raised
beds but they dry out more quickly
especially if they're not sitting on a
Surface like a lawn where they can Wick
up moisture from below I like to use a
drip irrigation system with a timer and
then I also add plenty of compost along
with wool pellets to my grow bag mix to
help the soil hold on to moisture I
really like these root pouch bags
because they're nice and thick and they
don't allow sunlight through the walls
and they also have nice handles so that
I can carry them around these right here
are 10 gallon grow bags and they're
great for one tomato plant and one to
two pepper plants each and like I said
before about three potato plants will
fit in a 10 gallon one you'll really end
up getting a feel for what you can fit
in them pretty much as soon as you start
growing in them I've used 25 gallon bags
before and although you can fit more in
them the downside is that it takes a lot
of soil to fill them and then it's
impossible to pick them up and move them
around your garden it's just as
important to add mulch to grow bags as
it is in raised beds or in ground
Gardens I like to add a good couple of
inches of natural Mulch on top just like
I do in my raised beds adding compost
and wool pellets to the soil mix helps
it hold nutrients but I do feel like
grow bags could have a tendency to Lee
out nutrients more quickly if I notice
my plants needing a boost I'll Water
them with a tablespoon of fish Emulsion
per gallon of water every couple weeks
or so one of the things I want to do in
my next Garden is add more grow bags
with planted flowers because they
attract pollinators and scattering them
around your garden area reduces your
need to hand pollinate plants like
squash if pollinators aren't plentiful
enough if you're ready to start planting
your grow bags you're going to want to
watch this video next and as always
thank you for joining me out here in the
garden and I hope you'll join me as I
move to a new location and rebuild my
garden from scratch in the next few
weeks this will be my third time in the
past 11 years building a garden from
scratch here in South Carolina and I
can't wait to show you how I'm going to
apply everything I've learned of course
getting out here and growing our own
food is a learning experience every
single day we're out here doing it